when it comes to Christianity when I
speak to Christians I ask them what is
their faith Christianity and I asked
them what does that mean to to to be
christ-like and I said okay what was the
faith of Jesus
simple as that what was the faith of
Jesus if you're a Christian what was he
you can't say he was a Christian because
that means to be christ-like so what was
his faith as a Muslim I prefer to follow
the faith of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him which was to submit in myself to the
will of God
man
[Applause]
we have one guys
and his final message
[Music]
how much respect I have for the faith
well in reality
nobody gave me dawa that's why I do what
I do today I had to
for fear of my life if anybody knows my
story about how the Bible led me to
Islam I actually went into the mosque
for the first time like with fear of my
life I had no idea what went on in this
building and my first impression was
that these Muslims are probably going to
sacrifice me after jummah that was that
was what I would
because the Iman was screaming in Arabic
and pounding on the thing and he was
pointing in my direction
um but after he translated into English
I was so intrigued that I asked for
proof of the religion because you know
every religion says it has the truth
right but my grandfather taught me the
truth comes with proof so somebody says
they're telling you the truth ask for
proof so I asked him for proof and he
gave me a copy of the Quran and I took
it home and I read it from cover to
cover that weekend and the following
Monday I took my shahada
so the reason why I got involved in that
when I when I heard about it when I
realized that there was a thing called
in Islam and this was you know
introduced to me by an OG in the hour
Way Way Back in the early 2000s I
decided that I was going to be involved
in this because I didn't want anyone
else to be in the position I was in Lost
looking for the truth and not having
readily available access to it because
in Greenville South Carolina there was
nobody doing the hour if you didn't go
to the Masjid and ask about it you
didn't know about it there was nothing
to search online there was you know this
was way before any of that I don't even
think there was so like the first cell
phones there were like big bricks back
in 1997 1998. so I actually had to get
on my two feet and walk to the Masjid
and find out about Islam so I made it my
Dedication that no one else would have
to do that again and that's when I first
started my online Dao was on Myspace
that's what we were talking about and
that's how you found found me I don't
even think most these people in the room
are too young to even remember Myspace
but that's that's how it all began way
back when what 16 17 years ago and
that's so that reminds me of the Hadith
where the Prophet saws paraphrasing he's
talking this is a this is a prophecy
that this Dean is going to spread with
or without us and it's being fulfilled
and we got people like you I mean we've
I've had so many different pastors and
former Christian people of other faiths
no faith you know but they get to a
point where they're searching what's the
purpose of life why am I here and then
they get out there and that's the power
of Islam you know it goes with the fitra
you know when people look into it the
pure monotheism and all the other tenets
of Islam the moral code it all makes
sense and now all we have to do is go
ahead share we don't even have to go
ahead and try to twist someone's arm you
know coerce trick nobody no just no
share the message that's it that that is
one of the biggest caveats of what that
I think is most misunderstood is that
people becoming Muslim is not our job
that's not our job our it's not nor is
it our responsibility our job is to
deliver the message whether a person
accepts that message or not is up to
Allah that he is he is the one who
guides the heart to Islam our job is to
deliver the package that's it and that's
something that that is simple to do
simple to do people come and ask me how
do I give down I said tell somebody else
about Islam what do I tell them whatever
you know that's it if all you know about
Islam is that there is only one God
that's it that's what the prophet
salallahu did
if you say there's no deity but Allah
you'll be successful I said if you do
something as simple as that you are
fulfilling your obligation but we have
to introduce the people to the real
version of Islam because the media has
done their job very well in fact of
putting out a very Twisted form of Islam
to keep people away from the truth our
job is just to Simply to pull back that
curtain because it's very easy to do so
because it's very ignorant pull back the
curtain and say look this is the reality
of Islam if you accept it that's
beneficial for you and if you don't it
harms no one else but you that's the
fact that we have to understand as
Muslims is that Allah doesn't need any
of us our guidance is his decision and
if we worship him is to our own benefit
if we don't it's our own detriment
absolutely it reminds me another
statement authentic statement for the
prophet Muhammad he said those who love
my Sunnah love me those who love me and
my Sunnah will be with me in Jannah you
know people think of you know there's so
many different aspects of the Sunnah and
then a lot of people you know how great
of a mission was this that this was his
way his way of calling calling people
Allah to the true purpose of life to the
pure monotheism yeah well Allah we talk
about the sun and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam so much and it is in you
know to follow his is is obligatory it's
mandatory Allah told us in the Quran uh
his greatest Legacy
the greatest Legacy of the Prophet
sallallahu Is Us we are his legacy we
are the legacy of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam that he did such amazing
work and then the companions who came
after him did such amazing work that a
young man like me in a small town in
South Carolina would hear about Islam in
1998. that just to think of how much had
to happen for that to take place in in
precursor of the internet you know back
then it was Windows 95 and the internet
was like what are you searching on there
but that is the the son of the Prophet
Allah we are the legacy of the Prophet
peace be upon him and we have to realize
that in order for that Legacy to
continue we have to do our job to
continue to to strengthen the chain
going forward are we talking about we or
we all of us everybody everybody every
single Muslim
we're the Legacy we're the Legacy like
if people ask me how do you know your
Prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
existed and was real and was truth and I
said but you're looking at it you were
looking at it the fact that I am a
Muslim in all of the circumstances of my
life is proof of whom our Prophet was
and is to the world this is why we say
he is the messenger of Allah because as
long as we continue to do our job
he continues this is one of the greatest
we always ask you know uh we in every
Salah we ask for Allah to bless the
prophet bless the family of the Prophet
like he blessed the family Ibrahim Etc
one of the greatest Honors that you can
give to the Beloved Prophet Muhammad is
to continue to convey this message
because every person you convey this
message to not only do you get reward
for that but
the originator of this message for us in
in the present age gets a reward for
that so this is a way of honoring the
Sunnah of the Prophet Allah honoring his
life and also continuing to elevate his
rank in the next we were talking about
earlier today and you had me thinking
look how simple and easy this is
conversation starters getting people to
think and you said something it was real
nice you said that when you were talking
now to people you were saying you follow
the faith of Jesus but what was his
faith on that well you know the top 10
reasons was was these were in my younger
years when you go a little bit hardcore
When We Were Young we want to just you
know we want to win a draw a straight
line in the sand now as you get older
you start you know realizing a little
bit more of how to get into the
psychology of people when it comes to
Christianity when I speak to Christians
I ask them what is their faith
Christianity and I asked them what does
that mean to to to be christ-like and I
said okay what was the faith of Jesus
simple as that what was the faith of
Jesus if you're a Christian what was he
you can't say he was a Christian because
that means to be christ-like so what was
his faith as a Muslim I prefer to follow
the faith of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him which was to submit in myself to the
will of God so that gets the kind of the
ball rolling that you say you're a
Christian you follow Christ or what was
his faith
and and they really and that becomes
like they're like oh wait a minute hold
on a second because because you worship
Jesus what was his faith did he worship
himself like what was his faith so if
you want to be christ-like you need to
go figure out what his faith was what he
practiced what he what he worshiped whom
he worshiped and you follow that that's
what it means to be christ-like because
what you're doing in reality as a
Christian is following what Paul taught
that Jesus peace be upon him was that's
how the whole Christian theology became
about but I would rather follow the
faith of Jesus Christ himself and that's
what we as Muslims do what's kept you
having this longevity all these years
now from when we met up until now
continue to share you know the purpose
of life continue in the dawah and we're
still here today alhamdulillah
two things one of them one of them is is
a little bit um what is the word I'm
looking for
um one of them is is a little bit
selfish and and and and that's
permissible and the other one is for the
care of concern of other people the
selfish reason is I want to go to
paradise and I know that one of the most
sure-fire ways to earn yourself good
deeds very quickly is that Allah because
the prophet sallam authentically
narrated that anyone who calls someone
else to guidance will receive the reward
of the guided one without the reward of
the guided one being lost that means if
you guy you help someone come to Islam
not only do they get rewarded for every
good deed they do you get rewarded for
every good deed they do you can be
asleep in your bed at night and this
person is praying and Allah is counting
on your scale as you prayed when they
give charity Allah counselors you gave
charity when they fast Allah counts as
you fast so it's a Surefire way to help
me go to paradise because like you said
about the top 10 we recorded that like
what 16 years ago I might be dead my
grave in someone might watch that video
and come to Islam and it'll it'll give
me good credit so that's number one and
the second reason is because one of the
characteristics of the Prophet was care
and concern that he actually cared and
concerned about other human beings and
their souls and where it would be in the
next life so I actually do care about
other people and I want to see other
people have a good life and have a good
position because one of the the key
characteristics of a Muslim the prophet
saws said that you wish for your brother
what you wish for yourself and that
means not just your Muslim brother but
your brother or sister in humanity you
wish for other people what you wish for
yourself and I don't want nothing more
for me than to go to paradise so I would
like that for other people as well
sometimes because we don't get out of
our box or sometimes because we don't
interact with our neighbors colleagues
and we don't open up these conversations
and we let others talk for us you know
the Bill O'Reilly's who's not no longer
there anymore but the others and Sean
Hannity and the other Fox News and
they've kind of you know toned it down a
little bit but at any time you know a
lot of times the media is out there you
know just like they had recently at the
World Cup you know the the Muslims are
throwing up the pure monotheism yeah and
they're trying to they're trying to
ostracize them and make them you know
connect the Moroccan players like
there's some kind of uh with some
extreme element you know what I mean as
the Muslims are rising but then we
explain that today in the film show that
we film this is the pure monotheism this
is the way of Jesus and Moses and
Abraham and then you know the belief
that Jesus's mother it's one of the most
blessed women there's a chapter named
after in the Quran so these points
they're so you know simple basic things
of Islam we went to the streets not too
long ago and we were asking the average
American you know 300 million Americans
we get to all of them but we got to a
you know a small group and we're asking
people do you know anything about Islam
and the majority are like no we've been
told that uh they're out to kill us all
salam alaikum brothers and sisters we
went to the streets to ask Americans
about Islam here's what they said do you
know any anything about Islam No do you
know anything about Islam No sadly do
you know anything about Islam uh not
really do you know anything about Islam
no I'm sorry you know what Islam means
Islam uh no we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us all right that's
what you've been told that Muslims are
out to kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you're gonna have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
didn't feel higher and what they did
know it was something just way out there
right so how is it now that you in your
experience now you know have you seen
over the years you know some of these
basic things that you know some of the
basic tenets of our faith the love of
Jesus the love of his mother the pure
monotheism you know if we just get out
there and share these things how much of
a great impact that it would make yeah
that's the thing is that that
we have to realize a lot of times we
become very lazy because we feel like
the world has such access to information
like oh you know people should be able
to find about it Islam very simply but
what we have come to learn is that with
the the greater um amount of access to
information the more dumb people are
becoming that's a very weird phenomenon
that we're seeing you know that the more
readily available information is people
are actually becoming more stupid and
that's just it's it's just a causation
that is very weird so we should not
assume that just because anyone could
really do if anyone wouldn't search the
internet properly they would find out
about Islam that they have done so no
that means that we need to be doing even
more to get out there and let people
know what Islam and Muslims are really
about because
we are going to be questioned we have to
understand that that on the day of
judgment it's all about accountability
that is the entire the whole reason for
the day of judgment to exist is for
accountability accountability and one of
the things that we will be accountable
for besides our own personal Deeds is
especially for Muslims living in the
west or Muslim minorities we will be
accountable for the people around us
because those people will now if we if
we have it let's say we have a neighbor
or co-worker that knew us for 10 15
years and we never told them about Islam
do you think that person is not going to
try to use us as a bargaining chip that
my Lord there was this Muslim that he
knew he lived next to me for 15 years
and it might not free him but it might
bind us you know what I mean it might
actually become a proof against us on
the day of judgment that you live next
to this person you knew where they were
going that was going to happen to them
and you did nothing so we have to hold
ourselves accountable
um not only that but it's a command from
Allah
jicama we must call into the way of
Islam I remember so we don't get too
dragged on but I'll tell you something
very that really changed kind of my
Outlook on on dower because I there was
a point
and I would say the the the late 2000s
that I was ready to quit not quit
because I didn't want to give dawa but I
wanted to move to Medina and just study
because I felt like I needed to know a
lot more about the religion because the
more you get to know about Islam the
more you realize you don't know about
Islam so I actually went to Medina and
spent my Summers there through the
mid-2000s and I went to the house
of Sheikh Abdullah one evening and I was
actually invited without knowing to the
to the meeting of all the scholars of
Mauritania at the time they had the
meeting at Sheikh abdullah's house and I
walked in and these were some Scholars
that I had no business sitting in the
same room with and I was wondering why
why did he invite me here he you know
why he invited me there he invited me
there to tell them my story about how I
came to Islam and I tried to refuse I
was like are you kidding me I do not
even have the right to open my mouth in
this room there was some of there was
some great scholarization was there I
mean I was like I don't need to do this
you know how he convinced me he said
these Scholars are like Engineers who've
never built a building they're like
heart surgeons who've never seen a
patient
because they live in this super
religious bubble wherein they they loved
that I was so much because they know
it's the core of the Deen they know it's
one of the greatest Sunday of the
messenger of Allah but they very rarely
come into contact with non-muslims so
they don't get to do it so when they see
people who have become Muslim or people
who are involved in doing that well it
becomes something of a of a of a love
for them that they love to see and that
changed my output dramatically
subhanallah that's where the dean Center
comes in
this is I've known brother Eddie and I
didn't show for many many years and as a
matter of fact I was one of the original
people who showed up on his show
alhamdulillah he's been doing a great
job alhamdulillah
through his show through those
activities in andawa right now they work
in hamdullah in a great project the dean
Center which is now taken this dawa from
such a small show to become nice
larger audience and they need your
support and I give them my support
inshallahu tala for the dean Center
hopefully inshallah you can look into it
and put some ironic charity and walk for
yourself to inshallah this project that
brings you continuous charity for the
rest of your life until the day of Judge
support the dean Center
[Music]
try to reach out inshallah to these 300
million Americans not just here all over
the world who know nothing about Islam
what was your impression you had a
chance now to visit the property and you
know about the projects what are your
impressions and I went to see it yeah
masha'allah what I saw was amazing
potential amazing potential
um to be able to to establish something
that can be a hub of dawah because
that's something that we you know we
don't do is we're organized about
everything else as Muslims we have our
our religion is supposed to be organized
we're organizing the way we pray we're
organizing the way we give charity we're
organizing Hajj well I don't take that
with a grain of salt for anybody who's
been to Hajj how organized it is or not
but one of the things we are so
disorganized in is that one we're so
disorganized in the way that we do it
and and it needs to be done in a very
systematic way in order to produce
results you know it's just like a
business if you're a martial arts
business if you just decided to wing it
every single day how successful would it
be would not be very successful
successful there's a systematic way to
establish a successful business the same
endowed we need to be doing it in a very
systematic way and and I've been
preaching this for as long as I've been
giving Daryl which is going on 20 years
now and and this is an opportunity to do
so along with people like yourself who
have a track record you know like we've
been at this for a long time we've gone
great gray in this thing
um so I think the the the the potential
is there and the organization is there
the experience is there but what is
missing what's always missing the
support the funding that is though I
will tell you Eddie and you know this as
well as I do and you've probably learned
it the very hard way now finding support
for dawa is the hardest thing to do
because people will support everything
but they think that dawa should be you
know something that should you know be
free to do but to do it properly
systematically in a way that's going to
produce results uh needs funding
and that's the problem thank you so much
my pleasure being with us again
thank you brothers and sisters
[Music]
foreign
bless your efforts Eddie
how you doing brother
all right so as you can see we're
getting to work and we need your support
so go ahead and help us to get this
where it's top-notch inshallah I cannot
leave without giving you a gift if you
are not yet Muslim and you tune in to
see what these Muslims are talking about
and you like a free copy of the Quran go
and visit thedenshow.com we'll take care
of the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum